from being a quirkless kid with no hope
of ever becoming a hero to becoming
Humanity's Only Hope in the fight
against ultimate Evil these are all of
deku's forms in my hero Academia as a
child Deku greatly admired Heroes always
dreaming of becoming as incredible as
them unfortunately by the time the
children his age started manifesting
their quirks he wasn't showing any signs
of his powers and he soon discovered
that he was born worthless despite his
condition Deku remained optimistic
always learning more and more about the
heroes around him as he studied Pro
Heroes for years he became familiar with
many fundamental hero skills and tactics
he was eventually able to use some of
those skills when he took on the sludge
villain in order to protect bakugou is
bravery and determination during the
sack caught the eye of all night the
world's number one hero and he decided
to train Deku as he saw his immense
potential after 10 months of training
Deku developed admirable physical
strength and was finally ready to
inherit all might squirk one for all
uncontrolled after retaining one for all
Deku couldn't use it effectively and his
powers were mostly out of control
furthermore he needed to be really
careful while using it as the power
could quite literally blow apart his
body if not used correctly one of deku's
first achievements with his new powers
was defeating an enormous villain robot
with a single punch during the UA
entrance exam although this was pretty
impressive the physical backlash at the
time prevented Deku from being able to
continue to fight from then on Deca was
forced to develop creative and unique
ways to use one for all effectively for
example he realized that he can
concentrate the power in only his
fingers and create an enormous and
Powerful Shockwave without completely
immobilizing himself by applying this
correctly and utilizing his hand-to-hand
combat skills Deku was able to fight
toe-to-toe with some of the strongest
students of class 1a such as bakugo and
tororoki although he had one for all
someone under control if he wanted to
get stronger Deku needed to find a way
to use his powers more efficiently which
leads us to his next form Deku full Cal
under the tutelage of Gran Torino the
former mentor of all might Deku managed
to acquire more control over one for all
leading to the creation of one for all
Full Count this technique essentially
allows Deku to spread the use of one for
all across his body evenly rather than
focusing his Quirk on one section at a
time when he activates full Cal red vein
like lions course throughout his body
coinciding with the energy flowing
throughout him learning full cow was
game changing for decades and it quickly
became a key component of his fighting
style allowing him to battle against
much stronger opponents than before
furthermore by studying Gran Torino and
bakugo Deku learned how to propel
himself through the air using the same
movement style as them this later
allowed him to locate tenure in hosu
city by quickly searching throughout the
area Deku also displays incredible
reflexes in this form reading and
evading Gran Torino's movements
something he was completely incapable of
doing before Deku first began using full
cowl at five percent of one for all but
soon increased this limit to 8 after
inventing one for all full Cal shoot
style and fighting with bakugou he can
freely adjust the percentage of one for
all at any time as he sees fit but going
over his limit will cause massive damage
to his body full cow enabled Deku to
compete more closely with his classmates
in the physical aspects and even allowed
him to fight against top villains like
the hero killer stain who had
single-handedly bested various Pro
Heroes despite Deku getting much
stronger than before his body Still
Remains relatively vulnerable to one for
all's drawbacks which gives him a
disadvantage against stronger enemies
like muscular and overhaul one for all
one hundred percent one for all 100 is a
technique that allows Deku to attack the
enemy using the full power of one for
all in the desired part of his body
sounds incredibly powerful but there's a
Twist the specific body part Deku uses
will end up breaking pretty badly
moreover further usage of the same limb
after an initial attack can cause
scarring as seen in his fight against
Todoroki causing midoriya to get surgery
on his right hand due to injuries what's
truly impressive is that while one for
all is at 100 Deku can activate his
ultimate move one million percent
Delaware Detroit smash this attack
basically consists of Deku using his 100
Delaware Smash and his 100 Detroit smash
simultane combining their destructive
power into one attack this is one of the
strongest moves in deku's Arsenal and it
allowed him to completely overpower
muscular an incredibly strong villain he
had no chance of defeating before it's
important to mention that Deku doesn't
actually use one million percent as that
would be impossible it's simply his way
of shouting his feelings towards this
unusual strength alright compared to the
beginning Deku has become pretty
powerful but there is still many forms
left that are even more powerful than
this one one for all full Cal 100 okay
we already talked about how powerful
beku is when focuses 100 of his power in
his limbs but what if that same 100 was
spread throughout his entire body how
strong would he be then well that's
exactly what he achieves in this form
with Eddie's rewind Quirk Deku could use
full Cal at maximum power because she
kept rewinding the Damage Done to his
body in this form Deku achieves a
tremendous boost in his overall
abilities to the point that he manages
to overwhelm overhaul and plays a
crucial role in divinium deku's strength
and speed in this form Rivals all mines
even gains the ability to move through
midair using wind pressure while using
the full calip 100 deku's hair Rises
gaining a spiky appearance while glowing
a brighter shade of green than normal
and blue energy flows from his eyes in
his battle against Fleck turn Deku
unleashes this power again but without
any this time he uses full Cal 100 to
release his ultimate move United States
of world smash completely overpowering
collect and collapsing the entire room
they were in this feat is even more
impressive when you consider that Fleck
had a reflect Quirk which seemed
unbeatable until that point two Quirk
statue black whip in season 5 we learned
that the core of one for all has grown
in strength from being passed from user
to user and The Quirk factors of all of
the previous users have merged into the
core this means that Deku can awaken all
of the quirks that past users had and
this is exactly what he does in episode
98 when he awakens his new Quirk black
whip blackwhip is equipped that releases
dark and Powerful tendrils from any part
of the user's body and was previously
used by the fifth one for all users
this Quirk to bind enemies and improve
his mid-air maneuverability however by
the time the Quirk reached Deku it had
gotten much stronger due to one crawl to
the point that the young hero had
struggled to control it the very first
Time Deku manifest black whip he goes
completely berserk putting his
classmates in danger and causing him a
man's tomb however after training with
bakugou and all might he learns to use a
less powerful version of it the key to
effectively controlling this Quirk is in
deku's emotions even daiguro tells him
that the angrier he is the stronger the
Quirk will be during the Paranormal
Liberation War deku's grip on black whip
became phenomenal effectively using it
to swing off buildings to increase his
Mobility he also uses it creatively to
support his main court and even uses it
like suyu uses her tongue by shooting
the tendrils from his mouth as his arms
were broken from the overuse of one for
all it's crazy to think that there are
still five more quirks that Deku will
awaken and become even more powerful
three quirks Deku float float is another
Quirk that promotes Mobility by allowing
the user to levitate midair this Quirk
initially belonged to nanashimoto the
seventh user of one for all Deku first
demonstrates this Quirk during his fight
against shigaraki during the Paranormal
Liberation World in order to dodge the
villain's attacks he then used float
again in his rematch against muscular
steering clear from his attacks and
remaining suspended in the air to
prevent the villain from Landing any
hits moreover due to one for all float's
power has increased allowing it to
function similarly to flight therefore
just like Nana Deku uses the Quirk
mainly for transportation to quickly
travel through the city whenever a
threat arises Fork Works statue danger
sense the next Quirk that Deku awakened
was danger sense originally belonging to
the fourth one for all users hikage
shinomori danger sense is a really
powerful Quirk allowing the user to
quickly detect any danger nearby when
The Quirk spots a threat be it a
malicious intention or a negative
emotion it results in the user feeling a
stabbing pain in their head Deku first
felt the stabbing feeling when shigaraki
severely entered bakugou he then felt
the same thing again when gigantobacia
was about to get free from the best
genus wires however he only realizes
what the feeling means after daughter
uses his Flames to knock him out it was
then that Deca remembered all might's
notes about the quirks of the previous
one for all users and realized that he
had awakened danger sense due to the
quirk's sudden Awakening and deku's lack
of training with it he found it hard to
stay conscious while the signals were
being sent to his brain so he primarily
used this Quirk as a way to track down
nearby criminals through their evil
thoughts like the other quirks nature
sins has some drawbacks for example The
Quirk doesn't detect anyone who isn't a
threat to the user like toga who holds
great affection in her heart for Deku
that's why this Quirk doesn't work when
she attacks him as there's no malice in
her mind five Quirk statue
The Quirk of the third user of one for
all is possibly the most impressive of
all the previous users quirks using this
Quirk Deku repeats regular Motions like
jumping up and down which builds up and
stores energy inside of him and lets him
use it whenever he desires as the energy
is released it enormously increases
deku's power and provides an explosive
burst of speed what's truly noteworthy
is that the user can choose to use only
a certain amount of energy making The
Quirk suited for pretty much any
situation Deku first uses the Quirk
against lady Nagant and builds energy by
jumping from building to building he
eventually gathers enough energy to
become faster than a bullet and
successfully defeats the villain the
only downside to this incredible Quirk
is that it takes a long time to prepare
and requires precise release timing in
order to prevent any energy loss six
quirks Deku smoke screen Deku inherited
smoke screen from the sixth one for all
users n and as the name suggests The
Quirk allows the user to generate a
thick cloud of smoke from their body
this smoke helps in effectively
obscuring the vision of opponents and is
often used strategically Deco obtained
this Quirk shortly after the Paranormal
Liberation war and demonstrated its use
in his fight with muscular due to his
lack of experience in the quirk's
increased power due to one for all Deku
releases too much smoke blinding himself
for a short period however thanks to
float he quickly recovers and
effectively uses smoke screen again to
greatly limit the villain's visibility
although The Quirk doesn't have any
offensive value it plays a major role in
5 when combined with other quirks for
example during deku's fight against lady
Nagant he uses smokescreen to buy
himself some time to gather energy using
fajing seven quirks Deku gear shift the
seventh and the last Quirk awaken by
Deku is gear originally belonging
to the second one for all users
initially gear shift wasn't as strong
and the second user primarily used it to
increase the speed of bullets however
due to the stockpiling effects of one
for all the court got much stronger over
time and when used in conjunction with
one for all it's capable of warping the
very laws of reality due to this
incredible increase in power The Quirk
became really dangerous to use this
means the Deku can only use this power
as a last resort during battles
furthermore when Deku does activate gear
shift he only has about five minutes to
finish the battle because after that he
will most likely faint due to the strain
on his body when he first obtained The
Quirk Deku used it to inflict heavy
damage on shigaraki by empowering and
increasing the speed of his attacks to
the point that he even broke the sound
barrier additionally Deku can combine
his gear shift in fajin quirks and
perform ultimate move called overdrive
when Deku performed this move yoichi
describes that his power is now at 120
percent which makes him the absolute
strongest one for all user ever click on
this video where we explained all 10 one
for all users in my hero Academia trust
me you really want to see this one